we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David Pakman.
Here's a question that I don't know the implication
from the caller, but it's actually a really
good question, which we talked about last
week on the show about what is safe in the
context of the virus.
Take a listen.
Hey, David, this is Christine from Louisiana,
right?
I was just wondering if I find this kind of
suspicious during this cove and I mean, all
these big, big box retailers have been allowed
to go almost full capacity at all times while
small businesses are reduced to, you know,
15 percent in California, 50 percent in other
places.
Do you think that there is a connection?
Because all the money that comes to the, you
know, the Senate and the House and all the
politicians from these big box retailers and
that they have a vested interest in keeping
their stores open?
Listen, I don't know about the money piece,
but Scott Atlus recently brought this up.
The radiologist that Trump had working for
him for a while.
He also said, why is it that a full capacity
big box store is safe and a small restaurant
at half capacity is not?
And you know what?
I agree with him.
The thing is the conclusion may be different.
I don't think the big box store at full capacity
is safe.
And we have a report from El Paso, Texas,
which actually finds that a huge amount of
the contagion is happening in the big box
stores.
Now, I don't know exactly what sort of mask
wearing requirements are enforced in El Paso,
Texas, in big box stores.
And certainly the wearing of masks would reduce
the transmission.
But this is a perfectly reasonable question,
except for me.
The answer isn't open up restaurants at full
capacity, which are very, you know, smaller,
lower ceilings, less sophisticated ventilation
in many cases, et cetera.
It's I don't think the full capacity big box
stores make any sense whatsoever.
So a very reasonable question, which I've
been asking as well.
But I think we need to understand which side
is the answer we should be leaning towards.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the San Francisco apartment
building smoking ban.
Very interesting news there.
We will talk about Hunter Biden.
Shockingly, we actually have something to
talk about now related to Hunter.
And we will also talk about allegations about
a friend of The David Pakman Show, Congressman
Eric Swalwell.
All of those stories on today's bonus show
get instant access by signing up at joint
AskMen.com.